échanger sur les actions mises en place
pour préserver un climat scolaire serein
lors de sa venue au collège les molières
des essarts le roi charline avenel a pu
rencontrer l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative professeurs membres du
rectorat parents d'élèves
c'est un collège qui a su mettre en
place les conditions d'un climat apaisé
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
a également présenté les mesures
annoncées par le ministre de l'éducation
sur la protection des écoles
parmi elles une organisation des
conseils de discipline simplifier la
présence d'un policier ou d'un gendarme
lorsque le contexte le nécessitent une
mesure effective dans le collège les
molières qui a déjà fait appel à une
policière
autre mesure annoncée une période
probatoire sera instaurée après une
exclusion
chaque jour l'élève fera le point sur sa
journée avec le cpe où le chef
d'établissement venir voir un adulte
pour qu on crée une situation de retour
à l'école me semble important
le mot quotidien et les plus gênants
cette mesure parce que c'est difficile
pour nous d'être au quotidien avec un et
la compliquer soigner le retour d'un
élève en difficulté ça me semble très
important
le mot quotidiennement et peut-être pas
pourrait être confronté au manque de
respect d'un élève ou comment gérer le
retour d'un exclut les enseignants ont
interpellé la rectrice sur leur besoin
d'être accompagnés dans l'exercice de
l'autorité envers leurs élèves ce qui
ressort des échanges que nous avons eus
ce matin c'est le besoin des enseignants
d'être accompagné dans l'exercice de
leur autorité et en cas de difficulté
par l'ensemble de la chaîne pédagogique
et aussi en matière de formation
prochainement l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative souhaite appliquer
des sanctions dites de
responsabilisation travaux d'intérêt
général devoirs supplémentaires
des mesures auxquelles les
établissements font appel dans seulement
1% des cas